a new virus with no known treatment or
vaccine after kovat nineteen first
emerged in China governments around the
world faced to staggering challenges
first to contain its spread and second
detecting people who have it eyes elite
test treat and trace the World Health
Organization says the most effective way
to fight the pandemic is to test every
suspected case the world is not
manufacturing testing kits and lab
supplies fast enough to keep up with the
rising demand about 20% of people that
have the virus
don't show any symptoms at all and these
people are responsible for probably half
of the cases that are out there so it's
very important that we ramp up testing
the difficulty right now is that the
reagents that are used that the supplies
are used for testing are running very
short all around the world so they're
shortages of swabs in many countries
health workers are depending on what's
called triage questions to prioritize
those who should be tested that includes
travel history contact with an infected
person pre-existing conditions like
diabetes heart disease among others and
symptoms if you don't aggressively test
and isolate people as has Singapore and
Taiwan and other East Asian countries
you build up a significant pool of
people who are carrying the virus and
then it's no longer possible to contain
it
you can only delay infection you can't
stop it and unfortunately Italy has got
to that critical point countries such as
China and South Korea race to develop
rapid testing kits early on South Korea
was one of the first to set up make sure
drive-thru centers in and around the
country
the houses of people are being tested
every day while many countries like the
UK are having to ration their testing
supplies at a time when tens of millions
of people are in the lockdown the push
to test as many people as possible has
never been more urgent Priyanka Gupta
al-jazeera